it's time for our Wednesday draft we
have a formula for Monday for Tuesday
for Thursday and for Friday during the
season Wednesday is the day we have to
come up with something so today the
surprises through the first eight weeks
of the season and no surprise here
you're gonna ask me a trivia question
it's gonna be way too hard I'm gonna get
it wrong you're gonna get the first pick
go ahead well I hope you get it wrong
it's not way too hard I think you can
get this one you're just gonna have to
think quick okay so stephen strasburg
got a win last night to get to the to
get the Nationals to Game seven in the
World Series Strasburg was drafted first
overall in 2009 who Michael Florio who
was the last number one overall draft
pick to win the Super Bowl who is it
who's the last number one overall draft
pick to win the Super Bowl
who is it keep your eyes here don't look
at the computer don't look at the
computer stay right here
whoo-hoo late Manning AHA damn it have
won the Super Bowl
no I know I I was hoping you might choke
it off there all right that was too easy
when when when you started talking about
Stephen Strasburg I'm thinking about the
guy that directed et that tells you how
much I pay attention to baseball oh I
get the first pick yeah first pick for
me and and there's a lot of different
ways you can go with but the biggest
surprise for me by for when we consider
the recent history of the New England
Patriots even though they have been
excellent at the end of the season to
see their defense come out and
essentially evoke legitimate comparisons
to the 85 Bears early in the year
dominant early in the year that's
usually when the Patriots are still
finding their footing the performance of
the Patriots and specifically their
defense right out of the gates and the
reward of that eight names with eight
nose start I mean I expected them to be
in the mix at the end of the year I did
not expect them to be this good this
soon and this dominant defensively in
2019 yeah I mean I think that's very
fair I mean I think Bill Belichick is
like basically sent warning shots so
like hey Matt for Tricia and Brian
Flores you guys were good and you did a
good job here in defense but I am
the master Jedi of defensive
game-planning and it's been phenomenal
in Bill Belichick's deep coordinator
head coach whatever I mean he's the
greatest thing we've ever seen in
football really but it's amazing it is
you know and the scary thing is compared
to the teams that they've had in the
last few Super Bowls you know maybe
they're not as talented on offense but
this is the most talented defense
they've had and it's just amazing all
the different ways New England can win
on a year-to-year basis it's truly
amazing so all right hmm I don't know
what I'm gonna go with here I'm gonna go
with Matt Lafleur that's going to be my
one of my biggest surprises the first
half of the season I mean come on like I
questioned you question him being hired
then we questioned can he work with
Aaron Rodgers and then it was old gosh
all right they're working okay but then
there's this audible thing what's gonna
happen there I got to give Matt on the
floor a lot of credit you know I
questioned whether how good he would
control the room and things like that I
didn't know because he's not always like
the most impressive news conference
press conference type of guy but we've
seen him in the locker room a few times
after games when when cameras are in
there he's very good and comfortable in
front of the team he's actually better
there than he is with the microphone in
front of him but I give him a credit for
finding a way to communicate with his
superstar quarterback who is used to
things one way and not only has he got
into his superstar quarterbacks head and
maybe change him in some ways but the
big thing is he checked his own ego at
the door to go man my superstar
quarterback is a superstar and he's
really damn smart and maybe I'll let him
do some of the things he does too and
let him control the game and we we heard
on the game last night or Sunday night
Collins were saying you know Matt
Lafleur sometimes talks about how he he
feels like he doesn't earn a paycheck in
the fourth quarter cuz he just lets
Rodgers do his thing
cuz he's so good at the line of
scrimmage and all of that I mean that's
amazing that's great by him that he is
willing to do that because I don't think
that's in his nature or his DNA from his
coaching tree and everything like that
so I got to give Matt Lafleur a lot of
credit yeah and look that was a very
real debate and conversation about
whether in to what extent Aaron Rodgers
wouldn't be given freedom at the line of
scrimmage the way that offense is set up
they picked to plays in the huddle and
through a predetermined set of
parameters the quarterback decides which
of the two is going to be the play that
is called and he's coached into what the
parameters are and it's a very specific
flowchart that he goes through and Aaron
Rodgers didn't like that and it
alternately became a public thing and in
in hindsight it was one of the best
moves that we've seen so far this year
because it allowed Aaron Rodgers to win
and it was smart of Matt Lafleur to let
him win embrace when you have a guy who
can make magic out of nothing and make
these decisions on the fly and just make
things happen so I agree with you it's
been a surprise because we all had
misgivings about the idea that you just
go out and hire somebody with some
tangential connection to Sean McVeigh
and everything's gonna work out Matt
Lafleur was very very smart to let Aaron
Rodgers be Aaron Rodgers and allow the
Packers to be who they have been which
at seven and one is a stunner as well
all right I'm gonna go with the cults
round to five and two when you consider
that they lost Andrew Luck the weekend
before Labor Day weekend they had two
weeks to pivot to Jacoby Brissette pivot
they did they lost week one to the
charges in a game in hindsight they
should have won but even then they have
managed to win five out of seven games
Jacoby Brissette is a fringe MVP
candidate based on what we've seen he
had that great play to extend the play
that helped set up the game-winning
field goal drive when he spun away from
von Miller in the end zone on Sunday
Jacoby burr said has been great the team
has been great coach Frank Reich has
been great and they have moved on from
Andrew Luck and and we kind of thought
they could I didn't think they'd be five
and two through seven games and I can't
imagine they'd be much better if at all
better than five and two if Andrew Luck
hadn't retired Chris yeah that's right I
mean I'm with you I mean then you know
we knew Jacobi percent was good we
thought that they could still salvage
the season and be competitive but you
know I think it's it's been phenomenal
and it just speaks to Frank Reich his
ability to keep the team you know focus
and on the prize and and just keep
playing well and Jacobi per said has
done a great job certainly not easy
I mean filling in for a guy who's you
know was a legend to that point and you
know I hope that fan base now is
back on you know as far as supporting
the Colts because it seemed like they
were a little bit like oh man
why are you how could you do this to us
Andrew Luck and the Colts are nasgo we
want our season tickets back I hope
they've realized that you know the this
team's competitive and they're gonna be
in the AFC upper tier here throughout
the year so a good pick by you let me
just say something one of these days
you're gonna make that sound and the
Moose is gonna appear out of nowhere
and try to make it with you to meet with
me now yes
you jerk okay you totally threw off my
point here but I gotta give her cousins
and Dalvin cook combo there was one of
the biggest surprises in football and I
don't want to be a cop-out by picking
two guys here but man they kind of feed
off each other it does start with Dalvin
cook
we all knew Dalvin cook was good but I
mean he's you know now arguably the best
running back in the game so that's been
a really pleasant surprise the way he's
dominated football games and then off of
that how could we argue with Kirk
Cousins and what he's done I mean just
answering criticism punching it right
back in the face and just been on fire
in the last month he's the number two
rated quarterback in football right now
he's got 13 touchdowns three
interceptions and he's only you know 0.3
points behind Russell Wilson to become
the number one rated quarterback in the
sport right now but yes it all goes
through Dalvin cook but nonetheless Kirk
Cousins has been amazing and the degree
of difficulty of some of the throws he's
made over the last week or last few
weeks have been really really impressive
so I got to give both of those guys a
big shoutout
yeah I mean they were done they were
cooked they were horrible after they
lost the Bears at Soldier Field they won
four games in a row since then and I was
on with Paul Allen our good friend who
handles the Vikings play by play his KF
hands show on Tuesday and and I told him
that the next two games are going to
show us whether or not this is a special
season for the Vikings or whether or not
they're just gonna be scrambling for a
wild-card berth come week 16 and week 17
at Kansas City at Dallas you win those
two games you're a team that is to be
reckoned with in the NFL this season
lose one or both and it's gonna be
Packers win the division and maybe the
Vikings get the five seed of the six
seed go on the road the first week of
the playoffs and lose so these next two
games I hope the organization realizes
how critical these are to setting the
tone the rest of the way all right last
one for me and I'm gonna go negative
here we mentioned the Vikings losing to
the Bears you know when the Bears beat
the Vikings the Bears were 3 and 1 and
the Vikings fell to 2 & 2 and the Bears
haven't won since then the Vikings
haven't lost the Bears haven't won and
it just feels like it's falling apart in
Chicago Matt naggy the coach of the year
in 2018 it feels like he's on the verge
of cracking up they blew the game on
Sunday
mitr true Biscay has regressed and it
just feels like this is a lost season
for the Chicago Bears yeah no real hope
to make it better because they don't
have a whole lot of draft picks what do
you do with true Biscay what do you do
with with everything in 2020 so bad year
for the Bears and I didn't expect it to
be as bad as it's been no definitely not
you know I don't know if I expected 12
and 4 again certainly but I didn't think
it would be far off from that you know
at the worst I was thinking like 10 and
6 and you know in playoff contention but
I don't see any way how that happens I'm
with you there and they were on my list
as well good one ok gosh there's so many
to pick from here I mean I want to say
the Saints defense I just given them a
shout-out Shaquille Barrett I mean come
on he's leading the NFL in sacks but the
one I'm going to go with is the 49ers
defense I mean the 49ers defense is the
number one defense in football you know
and I want to say the 49ers team in
general but I never doubted Kyle
Shanahan his offensive genius and the
things he could do there I was just not
that I questioned the defense but how
good
they'd be the team first off has in just
an overall capacity exceeded my
expectations I mean they're arguably the
best team in football but the defense
has been like I mean really dominant I
mean but whooping every week it doesn't
matter who's in front of them their
front seven their front four is the best
in football they fly around I think
they're the fastest most aggressive team
in the sport right now on both sides of
the ball and the 49ers defense
specifically is one of the biggest
surprises of the year to me yeah
unbeaten dominant and who knows when
they're gonna lose their first game they
got some good ones coming up they play
the Packers they play the Saints and
we'll find out more about how good the
49ers are coming up in the second half
of the season all right we got to take a
break
there's the draft Patriots defense Colts
and Bears for me Matt Lafleur cousins
and cook and the 49ers defense for Chris
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports